hey folks welcome to a very special
break out of our packs episode of the
lobby which we recorded up in Seattle a
pax prime 2015 great show great audience
thanks so much for everyone for coming
along and sadly though the video the
file for that got totally broken but we
did manage to salvage the audio so what
you're about to watch is an audio
recording with some crazy b-roll magic
courtesy of producer Marrakech and this
one is a discussion about what we think
might be the best game of 2015 could it
be Metal Gear Solid the phantom pain
Colin Moriarty ty rude and Greg Miller
chatted with me about just that hello
welcome back to 2050
never before has a year gotten so much a
policy welcome back to 25 2015 Greg
Miller from kind of funny com I'm old
news now yeah I got a huge pop on the
first hole and Moriarty some kind of
funny calm the other night Tyson ruse
from gamespot com yeah Hayden guys so
we're here I'm your therapist this is
the fo God post imagine games networking
ah Joss what was it like working on
their friend Mirabella oh god I love
enough time to even go with seven point
nine yeah here are you okay I'm great
okay we're at the pair of you yeah this
year's been pretty good for video games
a bunch of great stuff came out and the
next gen essentially here next gen is
here it's pro current gen we're curtain
day is finally here again that's true
thank you all the good ones are right
right your microphone still not on I
don't know why I better I have their
awful I have this problem a lot where
you just like can't stay hard and this
is one of them 00 talking about my dick
everybody saw flaws little baby dick a
little baby dick and there's so much
more Greg games coming edge over the
next couple of months as well I'm Lori
your makeup with marry me okay yeah
that's how I pretty soon when's it at
two weeks yes September 11-0 system p 11
thought of sep tember no one think about
it don't worry about it Mario's building
why do they pick good i don't know if
you've noticed it all over their
language they never say September 11
yeah no I'm they say they love to all
these dates the noise levels of time I'm
like maybe you could have just chosen
the 12th any other day this is trademark
Nintendo they picked something we're
sticking to it [ __ ] off like this is the
11th day of the eighth month ever hear
of our Lord's expedia 91 nine months but
yeah hey different cavan over here
yeah is that getting to you that's right
yeah I was wondering not only to me okay
the beautiful people of East London as
well yes Gordon Chris oh you never turn
up thing you ever seen have you seen all
of her as I was you're basing this whole
thing on I think it's more dick van dyke
okay little there's a lot of dick van
dyke you're a dick van dyke you got you
there the old me know you got me I'm
calling you a dick van dyke because I'm
I'm actually I wit I wish it was you I
wish I spent all of last week playing
metal gear solid ah oh yes finally metal
gear all week long it was amazing Konami
rep has come out and said it's going to
be game of the year they said you know
what we think know where the game's
gonna come out this year that's gonna be
better yeah what do you say tada Craig
Miller fallout 4 is the question I keep
saying and I keep referencing you know
like I when I wouldn't played at the
preview event I said so far this is my
game of the year when plated for an
entire week 62 hours in now so far it's
my game of the year in the canyon and
I'm not qualifying every other game
obviously Mario maker looks amazing
fallout 4 though is the one you think
has the gravitas that it has the thing
behind it that has everything we want
out of a video game right so like that's
gonna be the big thing cuz what is great
about you know metal gear is the
gameplay is the world building is
building mother base is all these little
things that keep you going and playing
even after you beat the story and
fallout is going to be the same way
theoretically all the side quests you
want to go do building out you know your
your little shelter your little shack
and getting out this way I want to stop
making cool thing like fallout looks
awesome and how does it compare to this
question and let's have a look back as
well let's sort of build österreich
behind it is nothing I already said that
the painter paints my even here so you
for you yeah so far come on and comment
I agree no what about you okay Colin I
know you're big fan of dying light we
don't really think that's gonna be the
best game that came out 2015 me that
mean it is so far whether or not whether
or not something like I I haven't I on
Mad Max although I'm starting to I'm
starting to consider the fact that maybe
the publisher doesn't believe that this
game is going to do very well soon his
wife not being promoted I don't know
what you talking about a game of the
only thing you saw was the game and for
an article that's like this hasn't
changed much in three months and that's
terrible yeah i'm yeah what's going on
with Matt I'm so I well I I'm you know
that bloopers outside you see the
goobers no there's like Matt so that
also they are advertised
someone's talking about the gap and I'm
excited about it and I'm you know we're
traveling cuz we have to go to Vegas
next week for for gamestop expo too so
I'm not gonna really be able to have a
chance to play it until you know the
fifth or the sixth prolly but I'm
excited about the game i love Mad Max
and I think avalanche is a great studio
I think people might be under estimating
how good the game might might be but I
don't know nobody here playing Mad Max
yet one person what did you think all
right yeah man I think you get the hops
in this game yeah yeah I think it's like
my it's my next rage it's every one of
everything I've heard or seen or heard
people talk about this game heard seen
or heard people talk about uh I've been
drinking uh just doesn't seem like it's
coming together yeah I was like there's
something wrong with it I'm trying to go
in with an open mind and then and then
obviously fallout yet is you know super
super excited about fallout but yeah I
think dying light still my favorite game
of the year and I don't think I'm really
don't care about Metal Gear show me
which your three wallet on come on yes
it's so Witcher 3 was the best game ever
it was fun but I felt like it was a game
that gave me like it is it itched all
the wrong OCD itch scratch all the wrong
dose of the HS train it was i play too
so on 70 hours to see Poland or
something yeah exactly collecting
flowers and his dad was a hag which or
whatever they were just like I just felt
like I was getting nowhere I played the
game for hours and hours and hours and I
might eventually like and then you were
like [ __ ] I better put that in this
gwent pack and play the Gwen Gwen was
going was fun but I just felt like I
wasn't get anywhere like after a while I
am in playing this anymore it's just
it's side quest after side quest after
side quest after side quest after I
could be over 10 minutes like it'd still
be saying that over and over again I'm
trying to complete a side quest three
more open up I just run by a guy there's
a side quest and then I fail it because
I ran too far away from and and I was
talking to christina actually and she
was like what a queue and I'm like
there's axe I played the game for 70
hours and I already know their ass isn't
it great you play that game for four
hours and then the prologue ends and
you're actually oh no this is the world
yes again yeah that's a game but I don't
think it's the game there's a there's a
bet between Colin ok and it was not
forget on the
funny forums that kind of funny
accomplished forum we put up I put on
your seriously no shame hey you know
what I'm an independent why do I invite
you want to shows this owner all right
we've us on ty route calm for such fun
yeah oh we don't want to go there it's a
youtube.com / Danny oh do I yeah uh we
put the other 10 gaming website
publication things in my prediction is
if Witcher 3 will win Game of the Year
from one of those right column says know
what he thinks that game by the time we
get the game of the year which it will
not win again really no I don't think is
gonna win get me there anywhere like a
port what do you think of that audience
that's that's exactly the I feel the
exact same way about Metal Gear yo you
think that about metal gate you get the
[ __ ] out let's go it'll be it'll be
probably Metal Gear probably be fallout
yeah I really feel like rocket League my
god or not oh my god that's gonna win
okay win one I get always just kind of
the crooks of this whole segment right
yeah it's like were crooks we all yes we
are in a but we are we I still think we
are in a bubble and I could a bubble no
I'm time talk about Metal Gear right now
I i think that like I talked to like my
eye of I have younger brothers are like
1920 they don't [ __ ] know what metal
gear is they never even play the damn
game you know like they play ton of
rocket League they loved fall out and
they ironically started playing The
Witcher never having played the first
two games not one of them is excited for
Metal Gear I think they do know what it
is i think that fans love it and they
know what it is I think Wild Hunt has
way more mass appeal I agree that
innocent members on the fathers are you
concerned about the MTV Video Game
Awards no I'm just change the buff I'm
the same way to be voting on Cape of the
year I know that's true but the people
in the bubble are also changing they're
not the same old parts that we are yeah
they are no not all of them but it yeah
I guess I sort of the game this is a
larger question know when we think about
games that are going to be game of the
year we think about the sort of like the
small amount of people i get to vote on
these like for websites and for a while
not that are voting on like the games of
like really really really meant lots a
time unlike a game a nightmare like a
solid five is really gonna let me lots
of you but because it's like all we were
playing this game for like two decades
and it's wrapping up the story and it's
mechanically amazing and all this like
Paula it's gonna like I bought the
stupid
boy things I gotta play that game just
for like like years probably hum right
ahead and stream from my house and we'll
both where he will have two TVs my god
amazing okay I got my booty I'm gonna be
wearing my hoodie in my deal I think
you're forgetting the bandwidth in our
house can be really one coming is that
right and then there's like The Witcher
through all tones another great games
that like but like not everyone played
it but then you think it like a game
like we are [ __ ] unanimous on rocket
League and I guess everyone here is like
you we're in the office every single day
like I have to yell at people yeah cuz
they keep playing that game and not
working okay and you're all out there oh
I know you know who you are okay so
seriously like they are they just they
eat that [ __ ] up yeah I've never seen
anything like that like take over
someone's attention like that just like
grab them my way the game is on that we
play and work on like the third Thursday
I like after work i go home i play my
girlfriend that's yeah it's just this
game that is like it seems like
everyone's playing it like obviously was
free but it's sold over a million Steve
yeah oh yeah like Jesus car like any
worries people had I bet that guy again
three on on the sound likes having
because that's a studio that's been
around forever i was talking to Jake
Salomon they helped them with the ex
conversion at 360 version like i was
talking to a clip paczynski like the guy
who made the vehicles in utt that 2003
is mike i would who's the guy who made
rocket League like they've been around
for a long time there's another time
they've had a successful game and it's
[ __ ] brilliant that's the thing i
think that that it's a good question to
pose right what constitutes game of the
year at this point no we've like
obviously gamespot's give me the things
like journey before you know and that
spoke to such a wide group of people not
just with down our own office and in
company the whole industry you know and
the question is will that happen with
something like rocket League you know
where it speaks to more people like
Metal Gear speaks to fans of the series
yes and I mean I have every intention to
play in that game but like again I think
that a game like rocket League is gonna
speak to a much broader audience it just
doesn't it doesn't like hit the mo
doesn't he have yeah of what a game of
the year anyways the one the DB it's
wrong that is the fact of life cool it's
in sick with me quote unquote in a
shallow game night like you this map you
go and kick the ball you do this and
it's not your traditional 60s the
beautiful get the beautiful is a
beautiful game Greg line
hope oh it's already spinning off all
these uh these pretenders to the throne
to have you seen this new one where they
replaced what as I'm talking american
football mumbai city replaced the cars
with people and it's called like Jeff
huh hahaha like I've never seen this
game in America before noon good one
nice I've been cooking that ever since i
saw i remember the first year i was
working at gamespot so buck was a 20 I
guess 11 or something was Skyrim or
portal 2 was going and Skyrim won by a
vote of three was me Cameron and sub 4
in the UK said the skyrim was better but
that was like so so close this year
between the witcher 3 Waltons melaku
solid fallout 4 alone forget about like
rating by rocket league it's gonna be
like impossible to be bloodshed should
we be picking anymore yeah what fun is
this hobby if it isn't turning friends
against friend yeah i guess you guys
have made a living really it's not
really it's not a really sexy headline
right like we decided not to pick game
of the year yeah here every so many good
games well out of out of respect for the
game that would have been game of the
year had to come out that your uncharted
4 maybe it should just win that this
yeah that guy really playing the same
mighty number that might be my personal
one but yeah well we'll see see what I
want to see how good it is online first
all right judge know we can do Jenny we
can start it's a trend I right we can
just give everyone a participation
trophy yeah you know yeah they're a weed
everyone's a winner best
post-apocalyptic yeah yeah best soccer
car boom time but I got to give a
shout-out I've only played half of it I
can't wait to get back to it I was
really immersing when I was playing at
one night was everybody's gone to the
rapture I was really really into it when
I was playing I like this is really
there's something special about this
game and I just haven't had a chance to
get back to it but it's it's super it's
super entry it's a walking simulator but
I don't think that's a bad thing cuz i
loved i love gone home and all that guy
stuff what do you want I thought you
were wrapping up going sounds waiting
you know me that have a question where
does until dawn fall oh that care where
it is until dawn fall doctors that have
a shot for surprisingly good yeah and
told on with the exception of we have
talked about this yesterday on YouTube
stage but with the exception in my mind
did the exception of daylight until dawn
is my third game of the year
and I hate penalty areas in the audience
and toes on is the exceptional and as
I've said it Dave out Quantic Dream
Quantic Dream which is hilarious and it
not terms of subject a subject matter
but in terms you know beyond two souls
was not very good and I needed a palate
cleanser a heavy rain was great they're
doing two different things in terms of
subject matter that you know David cage
like stocks taken so very seriously the
very serious people with Eric monitoring
and totally seems to know it's a video
game the other one is like exactly not
to be a video and I feel like I feel
like a until Don's gonna be a sleeper
hit and a cult hit I don't think we've
seen the last of that series i'm super
massive will make another one not with
the same cast with a different cast all
themselves there's the funny thing about
it is and i'll stop telling Craig this
is that the game might be the prettiest
game on ps4 as well and I didn't really
expect that especially the I want to
ruin it for me one but the interstitial
steams in between each chapter are ya
astonishingly pretty and the game really
does the butterfly effect thing is so
contrived when you really think about it
but it really happens like I told people
there's a trophy for saving everyone
there's a trophy for losing everyone and
there's eight characters and I only
saved two of them oh really and I was
like I tried my hardest except for that
one girl who everyone wants to kill oh
yeah yeah I know exactly what she's like
the hardest one to kill apparently as
well if you vote against her on those
cars oh yeah yeah so until dawn I'm
surprised I was talking drag this I
think this might be just this is kind of
just going to down too far down the
rabbit hole but I trace this back to the
order 1886 Roach was bad in that Sony
really got behind that game in some
respect at least on the line and we're
pushing and doing a lot of previews and
stuff and it just didn't pan out told
you uh but uh I feel like they I feel
like some people felt burned by that
game right and I feel like Sony had
another weird game and it hold on and
they're like we're not doing this again
like we'll see what happens because I
I'm surprised I'm not see commercials on
TV I mean brides I'm not leak when you
think about the amount of press that
David cage game gets as well and this is
way more sellable and it's like I ended
its weight harder it's just a better
game yeah and that's the crazy thing
like I think Kwan I think we're gonna
see Quantic Dream's new game at paris
games week i think that's a given you
mean sony didn't market something like
properly exactly like star hall never
hosted metal and like every other game
for the from the years 2008-2012 um but
I think that you know I want Quantic
Dream who i think has storytelling chops
incredible storyteller shops heavy rain
is one of the great games on ps3 to
really pay attention to this game to be
like this is how a game like this can be
playable and not just obnoxious at times
which I found beyond two souls to be so
I just kind of smiled because to myself
and I weighing the game time like this
is this is a better this is a quantity
that's done better than country makes
them hopefully people go and pick it up
as well at 2015 then I'm gonna make you
guys for pen and paper what is what you
think is going to be at the game of the
year Tyra what do you think uh follow
for okay call fallout 4 probably Greg
all out for you think I think it'll wind
if yep you kind of hope it don't you
because we've already had great games
we've had great with your great rocket
league until Dawn's wonderful we've had
I love broccoli to win it wa it'll be
amazing yeah a great metal gear solid
game as well tomb raiders your mother
[ __ ] Megaman legacy collection yeah
yeah destiny taken King spittoon what
else what else we got blood-borne Mario
maybe you forgot about your maker
blood-borne zone when I right she I
think people are sleeping especially
with some of the you know the core sites
i think you know i like blood-borne a
lot i do that i played it i played it
for a surprising amount of time
considering how much i hate dark souls
and even souls and yeah i feel like
people I pursue it's hard to say me with
Diane I'm not compare I know a lot of
people don't like dying like a like a
but I'm just saying the early games that
come out are always at a disadvantage
yeah but it was that same reason that
dying light resonated I like to like
five or six million copies because it
came out alone yeah you know so but I
think people are forgetting about the
same reason rocket Lee probably did so
well I came in the middle so many my my
house stuff doesn't come in and that's
why I think follow for has such an edge
right it's like the Oscars right now
they're all those movies that come out
at the very end of the year the ones
usually get nominated usually win best
picture you know and I feel like that's
gonna happen this year with follow and
to enter the point of Tomb Raider which
that someone had brought up in the
audience I'm sure to me there's gonna be
great on xbox one but it comes out the
same day as fallout 4 and anyone who
thinks that fall for is not going to
cannibalize the [ __ ] out of that game is
diluted because fallout 4 is going to
sell millions and millions and millions
and millions of copies and so I think
that that game is gonna just stay up all
the mindshare
anything else that comes around unless
it's called duty and maybe halo i mean i
probably paid to you later if they you
know there was like a fifth like a 120
dollar version i had like a like a
two-round your God is just [ __ ] that
control our that like today with a light
blue sports bra yeah perfect I mean I
could probably use it I difficulties
back every night come on at thai rucola
morality greg mother thank you so much
coming on a lobby so that's good so much
I thanks to a wonderful audience here
much obliged thanks to Josh all
marrakech in the back as well so hungry
and yeah we're out of here thanks so
much for hanging out with us whether it
be here at pax or via the wonder of the
internet will be back next tuesday a2
p.m. pacific it won't be here everyone
will be slightly sober and we'll talk
about all the great at latest games news
so we'll see you guys that how do ya